arriving in indian hoping to leave the
perils of partygate behind handed
flowers here instead of fines boris
johnson the first british prime minister
to visit this state and given a
reception here he doesn't get much at
home anymore
this the view from the prime ministerial
convoy flags fanfare and boris johnson
billboards as far as the eye could see
the day began with a tribute to indian
peace leader mahatma gandhi
as he only too wow knows this a
politician who's had so much to spin in
recent weeks to keep his premiership
turning and events turn into with the
prime minister performing a u-turn on
trying to get his mps to block a
parliamentary investigation into his
behaviour after becoming rattled by a
growing conservative rebellion
you were clearly worried about what
conservative mps were going to i think i
think it's very it's very important that
nobody should say that we're trying to
avoid scrutiny so why did you try and
block the vote because i what i don't
want to do is to have
um
endless discussion about this when we
don't know the conclusion of the uh the
labour management doesn't have
doesn't start the inquiry until the
investigation's concluded so that is
completely illogical because we just
need it it's a logical thing concluded
you were worried about a conservative
rebellion i think i think what i felt
was people were saying look this looks
as though we're trying to uh to stop
stuff
coming out i didn't want that i didn't
want people to be able to say that i
don't want this thing endlessly to uh to
go on but if you know i'm i have
absolutely nothing frankly uh to hide
here nothing no
steve baker who is a key ally of yours
helped you get elected a key brexiteer
said in the comments today the pm it
should now be long gone he should know
the gig is up that must hurt i
understand uh people's feelings i i
don't think that that's the right thing
to do i think we've got to wait for the
conclusion of the uh of the report and
and perhaps i could say a bit more then
but you also said that you wanted to get
on with things that matter to voters do
you think
that the issues around rule breaking at
number 10 doesn't matter to vote it
doesn't matter i apologize for uh for
the things i apologize deeply for the
things we've got wrong and you think
it's a storm in a westminster tea
company those are your words of course i
think it's i think it's serious and it's
important but i also think that we have
massive issues that uh people expect us
to address you you'll have notoriety
time do you really believe that the
party that the country will allow you to
to lead the conservative party into the
next general election right here right
now you're absolutely determined to do
that of course i am and what what i'm
determined to do is to make sure that we
continue with our agenda which is to
unite and level up
but as day one of his injured tour wraps
up the pm's headspace dominated by
continued difficulties back home this a
dangerous time to be away beth rigby sky
news gajarat